hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday
no it isn't it's time for the monday
morning podcast what am i doing
what am i doing oh geez the birthday
week i'm so full of cake i don't even
know what i'm saying
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday for monday
for monday june 13th 2000 june 14th
oh gives a [ __ ] i'm so full of cake i
can't even hit [ __ ] reset
at this point erase and start over again
this is what it is
oh billy frost and face i've eaten so
much [ __ ] cake
this month with all the birthdays
you know i just had this thing where i
got like
three close friends my wife and myself
all have birthdays and it's just it's
been nothing but cake
and then uh i by the way i had the
greatest birthday of my life um
this past week it was just it was
phenomenal i just i had the best day
and uh as much as i was telling about
you on saturday you know
everything that i happened um
that night my lovely wife was taking me
out to dinner
she didn't tell me where and i was just
you know i didn't ask her where
so we're we're on our way to the
restaurant she goes
you know aren't you surprised you
haven't even asked me where we're going
i want to be like i'm not like you
i understand it's a surprise i'm not
trying to ask questions to ruin it
because that's what my wife does
she just asks questions she [ __ ]
columbo's me
you know no i get it i get it it's a
surprise but you know what there's just
one more thing and then she'd ask me the
thing and then she'd figure out what it
was
and then i would get upset and i think
that's like a sport for him
you know they don't like that you can
surprise them
okay because that means that you can
trick them if you can trick them the
door's wide open for you to do it like
it [ __ ] with their own security
that's their [ __ ] their [ __ ] is like
listen you can go you can pick up as
much heavy [ __ ] around me as you like
that doesn't scare me okay if you start
winning in a cerebral way in on any
level
i cannot [ __ ] handle it so i think
that that's what the game
is i don't know why but anytime i try to
surprise her with a gift she just
figures it out it's so [ __ ]
annoying and she knows it bothers me and
she just she can't get enough of it
she loves it right so anyway
we're going to this restaurant i don't
know where i'm going
i know she just said hey i'm taking you
out to dinner and she didn't say where
so immediately it clicked to me well
obviously it's a surprise
so i was just like all right how should
i dress she goes you know just casual
but nice
cool but warm summery but what if it
snows right
so i'm like all right casual but nice
got it right so i dress that way we're
driving over there uber and over you
know having a good time and [ __ ] and
then she just goes
i'm surprised you haven't asked where
you're going
and i just laughed and i was just like
well i figured it was a surprise if i
asked questions do you want me to figure
it out and she laughed and she said no
so we were on our way over there and we
went by some
italian restaurant and my wife was like
oh i didn't know they had one of those
there they got one of those in the
valley too i didn't know that
must be like a chain or something i go
they have good italian she said yeah i
said well
my favorite uh chicken parm in the city
is at dan tanis
and then i immediately went like why did
you just say that
because she's most likely taking you to
a different restaurant
and you just kind of said your favorite
restaurant is that place
and that dish right why would you say
that you dumb
[ __ ] right and lo and behold she doesn't
say anything i'm like all right
is she being cool is it going to come
back and bite me in my pasty freckled
ass
what's going to happen right well
wouldn't you know
we pull up to dantanis i'm like you got
to be kidding me you're taking me to
dantanas and she smiled she goes yeah
it's like all right so then uh we walk
up to the place people got mass on and
[ __ ] doing whatever she goes all right
i'm gonna go in and check in
just stand outside so i say okay now i
know you guys all know where this is
going but i'm too stupid right so i'm
just like all right i'll stand outside
say all right you're good you know and
they have like outdoor seats so we go we
walk around the back
and i come around the back and i see
joe bartnick's mustache mustachioed face
i'm like what the [ __ ] is he doing here
and then i look over and i see my
father-in-law like oh my god they're all
like surprised
hey that's what they did they didn't
yell surprise everybody just went
[Music]
which is funny because no all the
strangers didn't know
that it was a surprise party they were
all just looking like oh no
these people gonna be this loud and it
was awesome it was like everybody that i
loved was there
i always wanted a surprise party i was
just always too [ __ ]
walled off and whatever it just never
happened for me you know
you put the there's a certain type of
person that they throw a surprise party
for and i'm not that person
so uh i don't know what happened this
year but she did it and i had a great
time and then afterwards she was like
did you like it were you enjoying it and
i was like yeah she goes okay because
the couple times
i was looking at your face and you
didn't seem like you were enjoying it
i was just like jesus [ __ ] christ
i liked it
my god
oh my god so
but that's what they do they're cerebral
people they're always looking they're
figuring out they're figuring
they they're reading what is not being
said
they're listening to the undercurrent
they're not listening to what's be
that's just how
they operate they're spies they're
covert people
they're stealth
so you can't just be like you can't just
sit there and be like oh my god this is
great
this is everybody i love you can't just
say that to everybody
they're still going to be but i noticed
a couple of times your fate what are you
[ __ ]
in the world series of poker
before i even knew where we were going i
said this is my favorite place in my
favorite dish
to the point i thought i ruined the
place and she's still still
still made me say it twice
after saying this was great she then
argued against me and then i had to
[ __ ] say it again and this is why we
die before them
it's just those little [ __ ] leg kicks
those emotional leg kicks just
chop you down to the [ __ ] mat
anyway so um i had such a [ __ ] great
time
um amazing food and
uh just amazing stories everybody had a
great time
i felt loved was awesome and uh
it was really just the perfect night and
then the end of the night
she had ordered a yellow cake chocolate
frosting
right and uh but because they ordered it
from someplace else when it came to the
restaurant they're like because of covid
we can't but blah blah blah blah
and then they ordered dessert anyway and
then we brought this big [ __ ] cake
home and i've been eating a [ __ ] slab
of it every day
to the point i i can kate give you
heartburn
um i just hate wasting food and i also
like chocolate cake but
uh after this slice of cake i just had
right before this podcast
i'm gonna have to tell my wife to say
like look you have to give this away to
somebody
or you know you have to like get rid of
this because i can't throw this thing
out
all right i mean i'm not trying to pat
myself in the back but i also know how
to bake a cake and i know
how much work went into this all right
i can't just throw this [ __ ] thing
out but i also don't want to keep eating
it because
um i just don't feel right
[Music]
i mean i've still been working out and
stuff so i'm not showing it but i i can
feel
that my body is like what the [ __ ]
is going on i thought we were done with
this bill
and um i've been ignoring my body for
three days going like but look at that
beautiful chocolate cake
you know i'm a crackhead with the giant
mountain of crack underneath the nice
[ __ ] glass chandelier thing you know
what like you're not gonna go smoke it
so that's where i am with that but um
you know what's so funny was before
we had the surprise party that afternoon
you know my kids and a few relatives
gave me a little birthday
you know celebration uh
i had a cupcake at that cupcakes the per
by the way cupcake underrated
it's perfect you eat it it's done
there's no more
you know that's it you have a [ __ ]
cake it's hanging around you know it's
like a friend's in town
um cupcakes somebody just swang by
no damage how you doing all right get
the [ __ ] out of here so
um i say because you know versi was in
town which by the way there's a new
episode of anything
better that we recorded at the all
things comedy studio with our special
guest joe bartnick
which is now available on youtube and
all podcast
platforms um i told them i said hey
tomorrow we're having a little birthday
thing because with covet and everything
they haven't seen my kids in a while and
versi lives on the other coast so i said
come on swing by and they came by
and uh they were both acting normal they
knew that there was a surprise party
but they were both acting normal and
what was funny was
um the only time i noticed there was
something weird
was versus like all right i got to get
out of here i got to go do buddy's
podcast and i said okay cool
and i and he goes all right i'm back in
new york so this is it man i'll see you
i was like all right cool and he just
sort of gave me like half a hug and he
just kind of
got out of there quick i was like damn
it's usually more of a
goodbye you know [ __ ] first he's really
taken to this hollywood lifestyle he's
barely [ __ ] saying goodbye
and partner just said something ah the
traffic i got to get out of here which
is normal
and then they both got out of the night
but i i i did not see it coming i did
not see the surprise party coming
at all especially you know when you've
just turned 53 and you've never had a
surprise party
you feel like that ship has sailed like
all right that's you know i guess that's
not going to happen
you know i guess i'm not going to make
it in the nfl
i guess i'm not going to be a jet
fighter pilot like tom cruise in that
movie i saw when i was 18.
you know i guess bo derek's never going
to run down the beach to me
you know with the cornrows waiting to
see me
you know you get you get you know 12th
hole of your life 13th hole you know god
who knows what hole you're on right
you start thinking some certain things
that just not going to happen a surprise
party
was one of them um
but it actually happened i want to thank
my lovely wife despite the fact
that she made me like [ __ ]
notarize that i had a good time at the
surprise party but you know what that's
not even her fault that's how much of a
[ __ ] i've been
over the years and um i gotta tell you
you know
six months of therapy and actually
really being ready for it and really
working on myself i'm getting along with
my wife better than i
ever have even back when we were single
no kids or anything like that
um it's been uh
it's been a good [ __ ] thing so and i
gotta tell you my [ __ ] stand-up act
is some of my favorite [ __ ] i've ever
done
because that is another big fear all you
young comics out there
if you listen to this [ __ ] that all that
[ __ ] where it's just like don't get
happy man
you get happy it goes you're funny no
that's not what happened you stopped
doing stand up
you stop working you stop trying to
improve
that's what kills you all right because
there's plenty of miserable comics that
i've seen
miserable comics and they stopped
writing and their act
stinks and they're not funny anymore and
there's miserable they're more miserable
than they were when they were funny so
that's a big [ __ ] myth what i
actually believe is if you find
happiness
and you kind of figure out who you are
it adds a whole new depth
to what it is um
it kind of stops you know as a younger
comic i had a lot of did you see this
what the [ __ ] up with that it was
always pointing out
not looking inward rather than being you
know and then the 30s it's scary you
know i kind of do this a lot
maybe it is something i'm doing
and then you get to your 40s and you're
like all right i'm an [ __ ] so
that's kind of where i'm at well i'm now
in my 50s i'm a little i've always been
a little late
so late to the party there um by the way
um speaking of uh podcast special guest
um i had uh
wolfgang van halen on the podcast
thursday afternoon
uh just before friday monday morning
podcast uh
a couple of months back and he was
mentioning that he had an album that was
coming out and how they were going to be
like
slowly um releasing it mammoth is the
name of it
and it's kind of brilliant how these
i'm going to say kids put it out put
them out now they just
sort of a couple of tracks track couple
weeks another track
couple weeks another track and then boom
they put out the whole album
so finally you can download uh mammoth
wbh um
the entire album is available for
download and i've been listening to it
like non-stop it's you know if you're a
drummer it's so much fun to play
there's a [ __ ] song uh horribly right
that i listened to it like three times
in a row in the car
got out of my car did not say hello to
my family
went right into my garage sat down in
the kit and i had to figure it out
uh i'll play a little bit of it for you
here let me see here
how do i do this how do the kids kind of
the kids cue something up all right here
we go
i [ __ ] it up god you knew i was gonna
didn't have the volume up
there we go wary all right and here it
is horribly right
support i like
oh man that was fun trying to figure
that out
thanks to davey lich i just said this
has to be in four
because i always think everything's in
it if i can't figure it out that's got
to be an odd time
it can't be me and my lack of musical
ability it has to be an odd time
signature and i was like no
i'm just going to count this in four and
i blocked out everything that was going
i locked in on the hi-hat
and i was counting it you know
especially if a riff takes like two bars
to play that can also really [ __ ] me up
um and i was able to figure that thing
out and i had a
[ __ ] ball a [ __ ] ball playing
um trying to play along to that thing
and i put the horribly in the horribly
right
track off of uh mammoth wvh and uh the
whole album is just
it's just a killer fun [ __ ] album
and what i love about it is is he's got
a killer voice
he's got his own style and as much as
his dad
is eddie van halen this kid is just his
own on his own
path uh which is really really great to
see and
i know that they're going to be touring
at some point if i get any sort of
information you got to go out
and uh check them out because uh i saw
them on jimmy kimmel they [ __ ] killed
it
but uh i was very excited um
and you know i'll tell you what's funny
is a song like that comes out with
just a killer drum track
and i get as amped up as i got when i
was still in my teenage years
as old as i am at 53 i still like
[ __ ]
i just got to go run down behind the kit
and try to figure it out
and then i think i'm killing it and then
i film myself because that's the only
way you learn and i just look like a
[ __ ] i look like such a douche
um or at least not anywhere near as cool
as i thought i as i thought i looked so
um download that and see those guys live
man uh because i think it's gonna be
a killer uh killer show
and with that the nhl playoffs continue
i couldn't believe it i thought when my
bruins got knocked out everybody else
was going to be so sad they could never
play hockey again but nope that was not
the case
the hockey world moved on without my
beloved boston bruins
and your new york [ __ ] islanders win
their fourth
game in a row
matthew barzell once again who's having
a playoff
run i can't even say series at this
point this guy is just
he's just he is beyond beyond seizing
the moment uh
i got you know i was went to a kid's
party today uh so i missed the [ __ ]
game
but i just watched some of the
highlights and i guess right out in the
beginning
uh tampa bay tried to get a little
cutesy
in the islanders end they intercepted
the pass barzell was off to the races
and he just went five hole right in the
beginning
right in the beginning of the game and
bartnik was telling me the host of puck
off was telling me
uh you know after you have like the top
whatever guys in the league the next top
10 guys
are all on the islanders so they are and
they have the coach too
so i mean i know it's just one game i
know it's tampa
but there was a lot of chirping
during that bruins islander series after
tampa won their series i had hey don't
worry about it bill you get past the
islanders but we're gonna [ __ ] curb
stomp you guys and all of this
they were talking a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know all those those was parrotheads
down there wasted away
again margaritaville all those tampa
people
chrome balls hanging off the back of my
truck
um vaping
on a track anyways um
they were talking all kinds of [ __ ] the
islanders gave them the old [ __ ] uh
didn't give them right there fred yet
they're going to win the series but they
gave him a nice uh how you doing
little [ __ ] straight right to the
[ __ ] chops
game one just like that taking home ice
and i gotta tell i'm past the fact that
they beat us i'm actually really excited
about the islanders possibly winning a
cup
because uh they were the guys that
knocked off the [ __ ] canadians
essentially ended the century of
dominance
of the montreal or the better part of a
century i mean it's [ __ ] unbelievable
what the canadians did and uh well the
canadians and the maple leafs up until
1967 and when the maple leafs
just stopped winning cups inexplicably
um
the canadians went on to win in 68 69
71 73 76 77 78
79 and then the islanders came in 1980
and that was the end of it the montreal
canadiens never again dominated the way
they did they did win in 86 and they did
win in 93.
um but it just wasn't like
when they they they used to win decades
or split a decade with the [ __ ]
you know maple leafs or the red wings
um red wings in the 50s i think one two
or three i can't remember
but um so i always liked the islanders
and i always loved mike bossie
um i just thought i [ __ ] loved guys
like that there were so many guys
like just those 40 50 goal scorers that
just dad
you know back when there was way more
open ice guys weren't as big like i
watched
a highlight the other day about um
just a couple of tragic nhl guys
you know one guy you know who just
was came up with ghee laflore and was
just as good as him and he just
he had that stupid addiction disease and
it just [ __ ] his whole career up
um and i just remember seeing highlights
of that guy and how [ __ ] when he was
playing on the nordics
how [ __ ] big the ice looked it looked
like they were playing on two ice rinks
like the size of the players now and how
fast they are
and the fact that they you know the red
line is just you know it's there for
just
show at this point he couldn't have a
two-line pass
there was no stretch passes or anything
like that it was just a
slower game but there was a lot more odd
man rushes two on ones three on twos and
stuff breakaways
and uh there was a beauty to the game
back then that i think with the
the speed of it now
um is just
it took a little bit of that away and
there's a [ __ ] reason now where you
know
there is there's a reason why you know
it's so hard to score 50 goals
you know goaltenders back when i first
started watching were stand-up goalies
until patrick walk came in with the
butterfly
um you [ __ ] sort of stood up and just
did a little kick or something like that
and it just it seemed like there was a
lot
you know they were a lot smaller and the
net was still the same size
pads were smaller and all that type of
[ __ ] so there was like
a lot of amazing stuff going on but um
anyways but i there was guys like mike
bossie
and every team seemed to have like a guy
you know they could get you likes
30. and then if you had a great guy like
boss you could get your 50. we had uh
rick middleton was our guy when i first
started watching and he just he was
always good for 30
40 i wonder if he ever scored 50. i
don't remember but they would just
like the stick handling and they would
fake defensemen out of their skates you
just
you don't see a lot of that anymore just
because these kids are so big and
they're so
fast and i think the defense
are so sophisticated now
um that it's a lot
harder to do like i don't know
just some of that basic you know pond
hockey [ __ ] stick handling
now i don't know they [ __ ] get behind
the net and they pick the puck up with
their stick and they slam it in
that's [ __ ] it is it's all unbelievable
but it's just i'm just you know partial
to that style because that's what i grew
up with
so anyway the islanders went on 180 81
82 and 83
and i still remember having the sports
illustrated with mike bossie on the
front i believe was mike bosse
and it's had the islanders as they were
uh moving their way to another stanley
cup final
and it said the strive for five they
were trying to win five in a row
and um an upstart team by the name of
the edmonton oilers ended that
and um so it's cool to see them
you know great again
and it's also cool as much as i hate the
canadians that they're still
in it because it'd be kind of amazing if
the canadians and the islanders were in
the final
or the finals i would the [ __ ] you say
it um
because uh the islanders were the ones
that ended their reign
they had come back 40 years later and
try to get some [ __ ] revenge
it's not like they beat him who the [ __ ]
did they beat in 1980
because i never thought that the uh the
canadians got to the
stanley cup final there let me see here
19 whoops 80
stan lee
stanley cup
finals let's see what do we got here the
1980 stanley cup finals
mvp brian trustee uh 79 80 season
the new york islanders in their first
ever finals appearance against the
philadelphia flyers well there you go
there you go well let's see who knocked
off the [ __ ] canadians in the 1980
playoffs
nhl playoffs
summary let's see what we got here
when
um all right here it is
here we go homers are the flyers the
minnesota north stars in the
quarterfinals won four games to three
wow i remember the islanders smoked us
we beat someone in the first round that
year didn't we and then we came
no no preliminary round yeah we over the
pittsburgh penguins i didn't watch that
one that was
right before i started really really
paying attention to hockey
i missed that i'm thinking 83 83 is when
i really started watching
i think religiously um all right i just
went down a [ __ ] rabbit hole but
don't count the vegas knights out i'm
not counting them out by any stretch of
the means
um but this is a very interesting
sort of uh
four teams left here we have two
a a young team in tampa they only been
around
20 something years vegas night brand new
last five years
islanders are sort of like i don't know
they're 40 years in
no 40 years in since they won it they
came around 72. they got 50 years in so
they're not the young guys anymore
and then the montreal canadiens been
around for like over 100 years so
um you kind of got everything it's like
the brady bunch you got greg
[ __ ] peter and bobby here um did that
make any sense well it did to me
um what else been continuing on with the
old movies i want to thank whoever
recommended uh
point blank lee marvin i second your
uh observation that angie dickinson was
absolutely gorgeous
shout out to keenan nguyen who i heard
his voice i'm like where do i know that
voice from is that the guy from dr
strangelove
talking about our precious bodily fluids
and it was
amazing actor an amazing movie
unbelievable cars
lee marvin at his best i just just a
great great great movie one of those
double-crossed movies and then they
think they kill the guy lee marvin then
he comes back for revenge gotta love
that
um carol o'connor's in it i mean it's
just
what's not to love um and right now i'm
watching uh charlie
varek starring walter matthau
and i'll tell you who keeps popping up
in all of these movies
is that is it john vernon
john yeah john vernon is that the guy
actor let me see his picture
yes and the first time i ever saw john
vernon he played dean
wermer and um and all of those uh in the
uh what the [ __ ] was it
animal house and i've noticed this guy
is like one of the go-to character
actors of basically the genre of film
that i like
the uh cop that plays by his own rules
the lone gunman the double cross crook
whatever the [ __ ] you call it oh another
added bonus of point blank
is um the helicopter that lands
in alcatraz let me see i don't know if
that's a sikorsky
it's before my time but that that was
the original r22
and it had no governor and you had to
you had to uh
control the rpms main road to rpms
um after you know looking at the gauge
but after a while you could just hear it
if it was getting a little low uh
yeah is it the s76
no no jesus not that one jesus christ i
had the wrong one
um
[ __ ] six
helicopter point blank
lee marvin let's see if that does it
still not doing it i forget the name of
it my instructor used to fly one
oh go [ __ ] yourself i can't find it but
it was it's a little two-seater
and and that thing was basic you want to
talk about you're actually flying this
[ __ ] thing
um it had no governor on it so basically
uh you were in charge of making sure
that you had enough rotor rpms so you
wouldn't just
i don't know i mean i mean the big thing
is if the engine quits
being able to enter an auto rotation
obviously if you saw yourself going down
the [ __ ]
i wouldn't have even had a a low rpm
horn on it it had to have had
something or at least a light you would
still crank it back up you'd know to do
that
but um it just seemed like way way way
like i've done you know obviously
learning how to fly they'll shut the
governor off and stuff and you kind of
see like like how much more added
workload
that is uh than not having a governor
but um
anyway it was kind of a cool shot some
of those little two-seater
white [ __ ] things let me see if i can
find this thing
that's really gonna bug me if i can't
find out the name of that helicopter
because right now i know there's like 10
pilots
listening to this thing screaming it
right now
the art of dying point blank
all right i guess not a lot of
helicopter pilots watch the [ __ ]
movie
i'll find out what it is and i'll and
i'll i'll give you the information
um all right hey and how about those
milwaukee bucks
you know beating up the brooklyn nets
after all the [ __ ] i've talked it seems
like these guys can actually
uh not you know not win by 40
every night um
it's [ __ ] insane as insane as
all of a sudden uh [ __ ] is is
talking about how he might come back and
run for president again
it just amazes me how gullible people
are
i thought after you know when those
people broke into the capitol and then
he was going like i
we love you all it's time to go home and
then once he found out he could get in
trouble for inciting them to do it he
goes
they should all be put in jail you saw
what he did
you saw the kind of guy he isn't there
still no he wears a red tie he's going
to make it
great again um it's a tough one though i
i you know it's a tough one because then
your only other option though
for democrat or republican is just a
total 100 percent
company man that doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the environment
are evidently children and innocent
people in other countries
they just keep doing what the [ __ ]
oil companies and the banks want them to
do so
i guess i kind of get it but um
you know i could handle trump just being
a [ __ ] [ __ ] i just can't handle the
race-baiting that type of [ __ ] and all
these
[ __ ] all of that crap that's that's
you know that's one of those things you
like to think has gone
but it's not even barely below the
surface it's just [ __ ] right there
all right and with that sip recruiter
everybody zip
oh god heartburn [ __ ] chocolate cake
what's wrong with me
um all right sip recruiter everybody uh
this copy literally starts with that's
why hiring can feel like trying to find
a needle in a haystack
let me make sure i actually copied all
the copy here
did he copy all the copy let me see
nope that's how it started all right
that's why hiring can feel like
trying to find a needle in a haystack
sure you can post your job to some job
board but then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along
which is why you should try zip
it for free at ziprecruiter.com
when you post a job on ziprecruiter it
gets sent out to over 100 of the top
job sites with just one click then
ziprecruiter's matching technology finds
people with the right skills
and experience for your job and activity
in active sorry and actively
invites them to employ apply in fact
zip
is so effective that four to five
employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day it's also no wonder that over 2.3
million business
businesses have come to ziprecruiter for
their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm you
with way too many options zip
find you what you're looking for the
needle in the haystack and right now you
can try zipper
recruiter for free at this website
ziprecruiter.com
once again remember go to this unique
place ziprecruiter
r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot com uh slash bur b-u-r
zip the smartest way to hire
all right there you go there you go i
know there was a lot of there was
some picture of uh old donnie boy
giving a speech with his pants on
backwards
and uh my buddy sniffed that one out he
goes i think this guy is
new york wants to put him in jail so
he's already beginning the insanity
defense
he was like you remember that mob guy
that walked around in his bathrobe
around the village because he wanted to
seem insane at the end of his you know
mob career and the feds were coming in
on him
and i was like jesus christ you're 100
right
how the [ __ ] do you accidentally put
your pants on backwards
unless you lost a ton of weight and you
were just slipping them on
like how would you notice when you went
to buckle your pants
your belt would be in the back or zip
them up in the back like you're putting
on some sort of evening gown
and then furthermore how would like
all those people around you let you go
on stage like that
i think it was [ __ ] um
i think it was [ __ ] i think he knows
exactly what the [ __ ] he's doing
um and i look forward to more of the
show um all right
billy royale hey bill
if you met a girl who you loved and was
perfect but she was part of the royal
family
would you marry her could you deal with
all the traditions you'd have to uphold
no i probably couldn't could you wear a
crown and learn how to wave
to the crowd like a dandy boy
you're already in the spotlight so you
have to watch what you say and how you
say it
would this be much different yeah dude
it'd be way different
i don't have to watch what i say that's
that is all can i tell you something
that's all a [ __ ] myth
that you have to watch what you say and
how you say it even after these
people who say they cancel people these
people
you know when they come back people
still want to go see them
they're still selling out theaters their
podcast numbers are off the charts
it's it's all you know
nobody's getting canceled i mean you can
lose an agent you can lose a manager
blah blah blah blah i mean some [ __ ]
like that happens but you know even even
then
you don't have a stand-up back you don't
have like a podcast
you know i guess as an actor you sit on
the bench for a few years and then
eventually you come back
i mean it's kind of hard
if there was no cops and there was no
legal founding
finding i would think
and then just the way people are going
about this [ __ ]
where i saw this guy was getting in
trouble
you know a couple weeks ago and this
person was tweeting come on guys let's
let's get it going
and said hey if you want to just dm me
your stories anonymously
it's like so i could just dm you a story
you're going to leave my name out of it
and i could just say whatever the [ __ ] i
want to say about this person
and then you're just going to retweet it
without
as fact i mean
i don't i don't understand i understand
like
you know getting rid of sexual predators
and [ __ ]
you know people abusing their power like
that but like uh
you know this whole thing now where it's
it's it's getting to the point of like
i don't know once you know i saw someone
lose their job over an analogy
i was kind of like all right guys what
was this what we were trying to do
stitch in time saves nine how could you
say that there's people working in
sweatshops right
and then all of a sudden you lose you
know how could you compare that to
sweatshops
it's weird um so no i don't have to
watch what i'd say um the younger me
the younger me
would have done that but eventually
the real me would have come out and it
wouldn't have lasted
um
the younger me would have done all the
things you just said
short of marrying her because i think my
friends would have teased me so much
and i'd have such a need to be liked
that i would probably break it off but
when the younger me i wouldn't have done
it i don't know how to do this
a long long long long
long long time ago
um
i can't tell the story let's just say i
was in a situation
i was dating somebody and um
it was really my one of my first serious
girlfriends
and the [ __ ] that i put up with
and this isn't on them it was just me
not
having any boundaries um
i very easily would have just stood
there as they dress me up like some
[ __ ]
guy who's in the military but isn't and
has some big dumb hat and then i would
sit there
you know moving waving my hand and it's
moving like a weather
i probably would have done that um but
if you're talking about now
uh any past the age of um
28 you could have got me up to about the
age 27
i'm not gonna lie to you i could have
fell for that but after that i would be
like no i want to make my own mark
in the world i have my own dreams here i
i don't want to just [ __ ]
you know sit around the castle and eat
quail
with white gloves on every night you
know what i mean
i mean how long
could you sit in that castle and you're
watching a game and he can't be like oh
what the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] boring i could read his
whole [ __ ] last name you [ __ ]
crooked [ __ ] right i couldn't do that
or maybe you can i don't know
i don't know and then you know what the
whole time you're in there
you're not going to feel like you want
you're not going to feel totally
respected
the old broad there the oldest one she
knows she's just going to be blowing you
off
the whole time like well you don't have
royal blood
you know you downloaded their album
but but yeah they
they wouldn't respect you
and at some point you're just going to
be sitting there thinking
what makes this pruned-up old [ __ ]
[ __ ] better than me
because she was born into this [ __ ] she
didn't fight for this
this already existed and they just gave
it to her
the [ __ ] is she giving i had a [ __ ]
paper route since the third grade you
know
this is when you're drinking some
[ __ ] 60 year old cognac
not corny is it cognac or whatever the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is um
but i tell you what i wouldn't do i
wouldn't make her leave
i wouldn't do that first of all she
wouldn't women like
stuff too much
[Laughter]
i would say this i'd say this if
if uh old ginger face
was a chick and his wife was a dude i'd
say freckles doesn't leave
i say he doesn't leave i sit there
you know it's not that i don't love you
it's just you know things are
complicated it's really
complicated are you doing to disappoint
my mother there would have been a reason
and she would have been able to cry
that would have made the dude
feel guilty and
yeah make her feel guilty and then at
one point
the redheaded chick would be like
well if i know and i hate the way they
treat you but
i just gotta say if you really loved me
yeah i can't i can't just racism i know
it hurts but i'm just saying
what about us there they would have done
that [ __ ]
it would have been that and that would
and she would have manipulated
it manipulated and hated it in a way
that she would have made it look like
she was staying because she could no
longer
trust the dude
right i think that that's what happened
and i think what happened with uh
old freckles there royal freckles
you know who exists on a level of ginger
that i never could
he's just he's better than me he is
he is right from the fountain of ginger
he's pure
he's uncut and ginge
i think i think he was treated a certain
way growing up
all right he came out he was walking
around the
castle okay with his freckles and his
flaming balls and he's like
all right who's kidding who there's no
[ __ ] way they're sticking that crown
on my head someday
first of all that one guy's never gonna
die he finally just [ __ ] died
right and then i gotta wait for the
other guy who's never gonna die to die
and then they're gonna choose between me
and you know
oh come head over here but you know he
lost all his hair but he'd know that was
happening but i
that's why i think he he sort of
rebelled he rebelled well the other kid
he was just like the show pony and he
had to do everything the right way
right so he stuck he stuck around
and then you know i don't know the
ginger kid he downloaded a little bit of
tone loc you know he's trying to have an
edge
he's trying to be this the street wise
ginger in the [ __ ]
white palace and you know it's just like
he just veered off a little bit and now
he's in
santa barbara that's how it happens
that's how it happens
it's very easy
very easy when you don't feel loved
to just veer off into other i think that
that's what happened
he didn't feel you know he was jan
and his older brother was marcia and he
[ __ ] knew it
they knew what he said you know what roy
i'm taking me real boobs
me cubic zarconia and i'm getting the
[ __ ] out of here good for him
i'm good for him just hope he brought
his sunblock
i mean he went all the [ __ ] in that dude
left
he resigned as a prince which i didn't
know you could do
and then he moved to a sunny city and
married a woman of color wait a minute
dare i
say he's ripping me off this kid's doing
every [ __ ] thing that i did except i
didn't live in a palace lived in a
duplex there for a little while
um living in a duplex is a great [ __ ]
thing
you know
everybody knows exactly how happy
everybody's marriage is
in that [ __ ] relation in that in that
little duplex thing but i kind of liked
it
um all right uh oh billy royale oh
somebody read that right college is dumb
hang on a second is that i think that's
my kid
what's that
you talking to me i'm doing my podcast
you want to ride bikes
all right i thought she was yelling at
me she wasn't
um all right dear bill joke guy
i'm serious when i say college is dumb
well i wouldn't argue with that did i
just [ __ ] something up here
why does it sound weird in my headphones
right now oh jesus oh jesus what did i
do what did i do
it's not you it's me maybe because i
made fun of the royals
not the kansas city ones either um i'm a
sophomore and i haven't learned
[ __ ] liberal arts colleges are just
extensions of high school
i've taken two art two history classes
that haven't gone much more in depth
than my high school classes
well yeah i mean i so all of college is
dumb i don't think they're doing that at
mit
he goes i have to hear she says i have
to take electives like music
history what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] i
came to college to major in biology with
plans to become a doctor
you know what would help me save lives
in the future and do my job better
not filling my head with [ __ ] like
why did ragtime
jazz evolve to mississippi blues
this would be interesting if i was
watching a free documentary but it's
infuriating paying 25 grand a year for
this
um well you know something kid there's
somebody that's gonna take that class
who's thinking they want to be a doctor
and all of a sudden they maybe they'll
get into music i don't know
the college system is a waste of time
and money and it's wildly inefficient
i've learned a lot more i've learned a
lot about myself and how to
and not to pick up chicks at the bar and
have made good friends
i think the stigma of not going to
college is changing a bit
will you encourage your kids to go to
college
um depends on what they want to do i
don't know that's a
long way off but like i thought you were
going to say other things
about why you thought college is stupid
i think um
think going to a big expensive college
is stupid
um obviously if you want to be a doctor
i think you need a little bit of
training it's not like you can go on
youtube and figure out how to do that
[ __ ] i think the the major or what'd you
say you wanted to do
um major in biology with plans to become
a doctor yeah i mean that's something
you have to
go to school for it's not like you know
you know i'm kind of thinking of
starting my own business
you can always take a couple of business
courses
at like a [ __ ] a cheap school
i mean a spreadsheet is a spreadsheet
okay uh the principles of business are
the same
um like i watched that documentary about
those rich people having that
their kid's head cut and pasted onto an
athlete's head so they could get onto
into a [ __ ] school they were talking
about prestige
prestigious colleges and that the
initial definition of french word
and the initial definition of it meant
deceit
a prestigious college it's um i think
you go to those colleges because you you
get to [ __ ]
you know your college roommate is bill
gates jr but other than that
one plus one equals two in a [ __ ]
state school versus an ivy league school
and um
what i found the keys to being
successful
is you you really have to
you got to surround yourself with
positive supportive people it's
hilarious because i spent like eight
years at the comedy seller
um
and so much of it comes down to like
it really comes down to you you could
have a harvard degree you could have a
you know
you could go to quincy junior college
right
just picking where i grew up the most
prestigious versus the one that
everybody can or bunkle here
bunker hill community college you know
it really doesn't make a difference like
nobody gives a [ __ ] about that piece of
paper
um when they're getting into business
with you if you have a business idea
like if you ever watch
shark tank none of them are ever saying
where did you go to college
they just like what is your idea how
much you in for
how much have you sold where where do
you see this whatever the [ __ ] they ask
that's all they're asking so
um but there's other things like you
know becoming a doctor and stuff i mean
you need to
you need to get your training so i would
actually think that like
you're one of the few people that's
going to college and amassing all of
this
i still don't think it should cost as
much as it does though um
i don't know i kind of talked all around
all of that [ __ ] but i always felt like
the way to go like if you wanted to go
to a very prestigious school is to
transfer in
after two years through your freshman
and sophomore year somewhere else
transfer in and then you're still going
to get the big prestigious
degree for half the money um seems like
the better way to go
uh but if your parents have money and
they can get you into some big ass
school and they got a great
football program you can get drunk and
act like a [ __ ] idiot for four years
i mean that's also fun too you got your
whole life to work right
why start now all right girlfriend wants
us to move to hollywood
hey billy butterbean i'm a 26 year old
guy and my 24 year old girlfriend of
four and a half years has decided she
wants to chase her childhood passion of
acting
when she initially mentioned wanting to
take acting class i was very supportive
and told her to pursue
it to her heart's content well a couple
weeks ago she decided the acting school
she wanted to go to was the [ __ ]
american academy of dramatic arts in
hollywood
i tell her to apply being the caring
[ __ ] bozo i am and she gets in
of course she did um now she wants us to
move in la
to la in january for the winter semester
we live in texas and barely make enough
to live in our modest two bedroom
apartment
when i explained to her how expensive la
is and that we do not
have jobs there and that we would have
to live behind
a lot of our two leave behind a lot of
our two bedrooms worth of furniture to
live in a small shitty apartment
she says i care too much about money and
material possessions and that she is so
disappointed i can't be excited to go on
this adventure with her
yeah i imagine imagine if the tables
would return
would she want to go on this adventure
and leave that l-shaped couch
keep in mind we were long distance from
2018 to 2020 when she moved back to our
state
i took a second job so we could afford a
two-bedroom that she begged for
begged for exclamation point now i am
the bad guy for saying i do not want to
downsize to a smaller place in [ __ ]
hollywood
i love this girl she's a sweet and
lovely lady isn't that amazing
after all that [ __ ] that she's doing to
you still i mean
you know but unreal i intend on marrying
her but how can i tell her she's out of
her mind and that trying to move to
hollywood to become an actress
is a [ __ ] fairy tale dream any help
you or the lovely nia is much
appreciated thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
no moving to hollywood and becoming an
actress is not a fairy tale dream it
happens all the time
um
so my question is is do you really
believe that she can do this [ __ ] are
you just saying yeah whatever you want
to do because you're just being a good
guy
and now it became real and now you're
going to say like your dream isn't going
to come true
you don't want to do that to her but
also
you know she's looking out for herself
here and you have to look out for
yourself you're both single you're not
married to each other
you're just boyfriend girlfriend so you
have to make the decision do i love this
person enough
to leave the comfort in the space of
texas
not to mention the texas mentality
to come out to hollywood to hear the
inverse of
what probably what you think about a lot
of things and how you see the world
and i mean what about you what about
your dream
i think this is a time to be selfish
in that you have to figure out what you
want this is one of these things you're
not you're not being self
she's going after what she wants and she
doesn't give a [ __ ] about dragging you
out there
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
quality of life that you're gonna
live while she's there she doesn't give
a [ __ ]
she's she's got her eye on the prize and
she wants to go get this [ __ ] which
there's nothing wrong with that
so what you got to do you almost got to
be the chick here
you got to be like well what's in it for
me you got to put a ring on my finger if
i'm going gonna go out that's what they
do but she wins that too if so
i don't know um
i don't know man can't you just find
some chick that likes the line dance and
driving the
[ __ ] rubbing your dick in a [ __ ]
chevy silverado as you drive down the
street listening to travis tritt i mean
there's got to be a million of those out
there right
why don't you just do that why don't you
just say listen you know i think we had
a great run
i don't want to move out there i don't
want to ruin your [ __ ] dream
but my dream is not to you know
live in l.a and you know watch somebody
else's dream come true
my dreams stay right here in texas right
give myself a spread north of dallas
have a woman that can make me some
chicken and biscuits
listening to country music what would
you do
you had to give your life for freedom
uh what would you do um yeah you got to
figure out what you want here buddy
um it all depends you know some people
don't mind like
i don't know i think if you want to be
like a house husband
because at that point you know she goes
out makes she's going to be on set
[ __ ] all day long somebody's going to
be have to be at home with the kids
you know i don't know that's a tough one
and and that is a big ask for you to
move all the way out there
um but if that's what she really wants
or wants to do
i want her to do it and i just want you
to do what's right for you
which is what you have to figure out
which it sounds to me that you think
like
you actually the fact that you think her
dream is ridiculous which is what it
sounds like
i would not go out there because at some
point
you're going to be [ __ ] pissed you
know when rodeo season starts and you're
watching it on some little square tv and
she's over in the corner going to be
or not to be and you're like what the
[ __ ] you let's make me a [ __ ]
sandwich
instead of sitting over there doing that
bloody daddy [ __ ]
i'm just worried i just don't want you
to get involved in that
um there have been a lot of stereotypes
in this story
and uh it's because i'm ignorant all
right what should what i should have
said oh one of my favorite things here
what i should have said how many times
does somebody say something to you
they're out of line right they're in
your kitchen they're writing your
[ __ ] grill
whatever expression you like and what
happens
you kind of freeze up in the moment
you're like what the [ __ ] and then
the moment that you should have said
something goes away and as you're
walking away as you're driving away
a year later [ __ ] a week later
whatever you realize what you should
have said this is what this segment is
about
number one here we go pool douche
yo long time listener first time writer
i've always wanted to say that and it's
true
i'm writing in about the passive
aggressive people you spoke about on
thursday
and i almost always find myself in that
situation
where i'm just like oh okay and i never
even noticed what happened until
after the fact anyways all capitals
um i was at my local ymca
taking a swim in the pool and this dad
and his kid comes in
the kid looks about 15 16 ish and almost
immediately the lifeguard
asks the kid to help him
set up the floating lane diver thing
divider thingy i was watching them out
of curiosity because i never saw it done
before
when they got done the kid sees me
looking and squares up a little bit and
says is there a problem here
confused i kind of just went oh no it's
just watching you guys hook the thing up
i've never seen it done before then he
goes
okay with a that's what i thought tone
oh an attitude
oh that reminds you know something i
know that feeling
and i think the beatles wrote a song
about it
boy you're gonna carry that weight
carry that weight a long time
that's gonna stay with you i continue to
swim for a good couple of minutes before
getting
out to go hit the showers and it wasn't
until then that i picked up on what
happened
i was literally in the showered naked
jumping up and down on anger saying how
much i would [ __ ] that kid up
i wanted to drown his little ass and
send his body floating back over to his
dad oh my god dude yeah
oh my god yeah so much [ __ ] comes out
when you're in the shower
regret things you should have said
shame i don't know what it is about the
shower that's when i just i just
start thinking over my life you just do
a bit about that you start trying to
shout all the bad thoughts out of your
head because they're embarrassing
you just start thinking like
is everything all right in there i think
i did that on one of my
little [ __ ] routines there anyway
that's really all love the podcast love
the family stay happy stay
safe and healthy and i'll see your bald
ass
in bethlehem um bethlehem
where is that is that in israel was that
jerusalem
does bethlehem still exist yeah jesus
bethlehem city well there's one in
pennsylvania
is there one in israel anything is
biblical i just say israel
there is
oh jesus did the control of bethlehem
pass from the ottomans to the british
at the end of world war one bethlehem
came under jordanian rule
during the 1948 arab israeli war
all right well there you go all right
we conveniently spoke around a number of
groups in that little description
shopping cart douche all right hey billy
something insulting that starts with b
no don't tap out like that
i still love billy babushka uh got one
of those stories about wishing i had
said something for you
i was 18 or 19 as a working as a
shopping cart wrangler
at the only supermarket in town i'm
sweating my sack off
sweating my sack off during the
pre-fourth of july rush to keep up with
the flood of people coming in and out
i'm stepping out onto the sidewalk to
get more
when a guy in his mid 40s walking into
the store
asks me to grab a shopping cart for him
they're all of six feet from where he's
standing
i say no problem in my best customer
service voice and turn around to grab
one
and hear him say um i think you mean yes
sir
because no problem makes it sound like
i'm inconveniencing you
oh god who raised that person
you know what you don't at the end of
the story i'll tell you why
you can actually find humor in that um i
get what he means
i don't get what he means don't [ __ ]
be
oh my god don't don't don't find an
excuse for this [ __ ] guy
he goes i get what i mean but he went
from being all casual
asking for a favor to holier than thou
[ __ ]
huffer i mean heifer trying to put a
teenager in his place
i'm pretty sure all i said was yeah and
handed the card off to him but i think
about this guy
at least once a month just know that
this guy's existent is
existence is he gets off
on on saying that as a grown man to a
teenager
make a minimum wage collecting [ __ ]
grocery carts
you know that's the kind of person he is
and the way he made you feel is how he
makes most people feel
and and when you go around living like
that yeah you have a [ __ ] life
he's gonna have a [ __ ] life just know
that what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i think you mean yes sir no i think
i meant
no problem
i think i meant i might shove this lv up
your [ __ ] ass
now i'm upset with this [ __ ] guy
oh god
you know what this should be like a
superhero for that type of a moment
that just flies in and just says what
you want to say
so you can't get fired or punches him in
the face and you can't i
use i wrote a sketch about that
about a superhero that comes in when you
want to punch somebody in the face but
either you can't beat him up
or you're going to go to jail and this
superhero would come and
he was called the dropper and someone
would just be a [ __ ] [ __ ] to you
man or woman and this [ __ ] dude would
come in with this cape
and just blast him right in the face and
before you could thank him
he'd fly away that would have been a
perfect job right there for the dropper
i think you mean yes sir because no
problem means it sounds like i'm
inconveniencing you
bam thank you mass man
all right bill bursho hey bill i have a
great
what i should have said moment that
actually took place at one of your shows
uh
center in the square kitchener ontario
i was with a few friends oh man i always
have a great time in ontario i always
seem to
one time i went there in the summer the
other times two times has been
in the winter when you can skate along
the canal that's [ __ ] amazing
uh i was there pretty soon with global
warming you'd just be rollerblading
i was there with a few friends and we
were having a blast watching your
openers and getting pumped
to see your act right before you came on
some drunk [ __ ] sits a few seats down
from us and proceeds to start talking
through the entire show
he was responding to things you were
saying as if he thought he was having a
one-on-one conversation with you
generally just being annoying a few
minutes go by when i finally say hey
shut up
to which he responds hey why don't you
mind your own [ __ ] business
in an extremely expressive tone i was
too stunned
and was to respond in the moment and he
went on talking through the rest of the
show
that's interesting to me that you had
the balls to say hey shut up
and then you kind of retreated i've been
there too
sometimes this moment pops into my head
and i think about what i should have
said maybe something like
i paid x amount of dollars to see this
show so it is my [ __ ] business
or something to that effect what do you
think um
you know what most of these are it's
just you're raised right
and you have too much to lose somebody
comes in that
[ __ ] drunk and acts like that much of
a douche
um they they don't care about just
starting
swinging on somebody and going to jail
and having a court case and all of that
type of [ __ ]
and the reality is so many people have
these stories because you're a [ __ ]
adult
and you can't walk around
certainly as a man you just can't walk
around saying everything that you're
thinking
because you can get the [ __ ] kicked out
of you
i don't know how it works with women
there's like i don't know how their deal
is
i mean if you base all of them on the
real housewives which is not fair they
pretty much
say whatever the [ __ ] they think no
matter how mean this [ __ ] is
um i don't know is that why they outlive
us
not because i say they're nagging us to
death maybe it's because they just
[ __ ] say everything that
it's a two-way street you know what i
mean
i don't know don't listen to me
don't listen to me but uh you shouldn't
say these things you should have a lot
of what i should have said
um i fortunately don't have a lot of
those
um in my
with my wife i kind of say i i what i
have with my wife is i have
i wish i i should have said it this way
um which is a good thing because
saying things another way usually that
first way you want to say it
when you're when you're pissed is it
it's never going to come out good
because it's usually prefaced with well
i'll tell you why you [ __ ] [ __ ]
at that point nobody's listening it's
like you have to somehow
master your emotions
and just be like you know and i'm
telling a story right now on stage
about this great argument i got into
with my wife
um where she was right
and i acknowledged that she was right
and then i wanted to do me a favor and
it's a long [ __ ]
convoluted [ __ ] thing here i don't
know if that's the right word
but i said something in the middle of
that argument
that kind of changed things in a great
way in that argument and
the last like 10 days of my life
um and to hear that story you're gonna
have to come out to vegas
that was just complete [ __ ] that was
just me trying to [ __ ]
hype my show and if you'd like to hear
the rest of this funny thought
come out to the cosmopolitan in las
vegas
july 3rd um
no don't beat yourself up over that uh
you know what you do is you uh
what's great about becoming a comedian
is then you can immediately go on stage
and you tell that story and then you get
something out of it
um you get a laugh out of it you get
other comics saying that's a great news
story or a joke
and uh then you also get to say the
thing that you wish just said
then if you're smart enough as a comic
you [ __ ]
say everything you just said and talk
about what how much it bugs you and how
you've been
you're going to think about it for years
or whatever and that's the thing that
everybody relates to
and then that's what you know you get
that great laugh that's beyond just
laughing they're laughing because they
relate
and they know what you're talking about
so anyway what a [ __ ] dick man
i'm not gonna lie to you i have to walk
that last one off a little bit oh what a
douche who
says that i think you mean
yes sir
i mean does that even sound like
something that a person would even say
in that moment doesn't that to me that
sounds like you know
like a like a a bad movie where they're
showing like uh
you know where they're overly writing a
character like
this person's a dick just for the sake
of being a dick like there's no
back story like this guy's an [ __ ]
this guy is nice you know when you're
watching some
terrible movie there's no layers to
anything they're peop they're not even
people they're just uh they're
adjectives
[ __ ] hero hottie right
[ __ ] i'm just babbling about this
[ __ ] guy you know what buddy you
don't need that because i'm gonna carry
that
wait a long time all right that is it
that is the podcast congratulations to
the islanders let's go
bolts man i want to see a seven game
series
because i am emotionally not tied to
this [ __ ] anymore
and i know islander fans and tampa fans
don't want seven games
because they don't want to die a
thousand deaths but i don't give a [ __ ]
because i'm out i just want my
entertainment and uh
you know i'm rooting for the vegas
knights and um
and uh yeah i think i'm rooting i think
you know with everybody left
i think i gotta go islanders
just because it takes me back to
watching the nhl
on the usa network way back in the day
the usa network
lanny mcdonald al mcguinness kelly
lindberg rest his soul
eddie belfore
who else was around marcel dion
[ __ ] gila floor
[Music]
gui cabinet
the [ __ ] stasny brothers brothers
colorado rockies
all right sorry that's the podcast well
you hung around didn't you you stuck
around didn't you god bless you
i will check in with you [ __ ]
on uh
was it thursday right all right go [ __ ]
yourselves